welcome to episode 28 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i speak with michael
goldstein aka
bitstein on twitter michael's a bitcoin
entrepreneur and spokesperson for it
i asked him to come on the podcast to
give me a simplified rundown of what
bitcoin is and how it works
he tried to keep his explanations about
bitcoin simple so hopefully this episode
can give you a bit of an introduction to
bitcoin
something i think people should know at
least a little bit about
michael also runs the website
justmeet.co
which is full of insanely valuable
resources for
information on a carnivorous diet or
even just for health benefits regarding
meat
if you need somewhere to go he's put
together a huge list of articles on the
diet
i hope you enjoyed this episode and get
to know a bit more about bitcoin through
it
i would like to thank true local for
sponsoring the episode true local is the
company i buy my meat from
true local partners with local farmers
and butchers in your area
to source high quality sustainable meat
like 100
grass-fed and grass-finished beef
pasture-raised
or rwa chickens raised without
antibiotics
lamb buffalo and over 100 different cuts
of meat that you may not be able to find
at your grocery store sausages some of
the meat has seasoning and is made ready
to eat
not that the unseasoned meat isn't ready
to go obviously that's what i eat
i get their rib eyes strip lines and
their lamb mainly which is the tastiest
lamb i've
ever had although their wild salmon is
great too
you build your own personalized box that
will give you only the products you want
and it shows up at your door
flash frozen use the code mp
to get two free ribeyes with your order
i changed the code from michaela
although that code still works too
nobody spells michaela properly so the
code is now mp
thank you true local for sponsoring this
episode remember to use the code
mp for free stakes with your order
please remember to subscribe and leave a
review if you enjoy the episode
and would like to hear more
[Music]
hello michael goldstein and welcome to
my podcast
hey thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited about this i want to
learn more about bitcoin and i've delved
into it a little bit myself
but i wanted to invite somebody on to
kind of give an overview to people who
aren't
familiar with bitcoin about what bitcoin
is how to use it
and delve into a lot of the commonly
asked questions and i thought you would
be the perfect person to do that with
yeah well thank you i'm glad to see that
uh you know the the peterson dynasty is
showing interest
in the magic internet money known as
bitcoin
oh yeah we're we're interested in
anything weird and
potentially useful so i'm looking
forward to this
maybe we should just start off by you
a brief background about who you are and
what you do
just so my audience knows who you are
and what you do
yeah so my name is michael goldstein and
i am
the co-founder and president of the
satoshi nakamoto institute which is a
website dedicated to the
economics and history of bitcoin and its
predecessors
the in the sort of cypherpunk
and crypto anarchist tradition i am also
the co-host of the noted bitcoin podcast
which is a bitcoin podcast and i've been
deep in the world of bitcoin for many
years now i got into it during college
i had already been studying austrian
economics for many years
and so when i learned about bitcoin i
quickly realized it was
basically everything i could ever hope
and dream for
and i've just been kind of in that world
ever since
tweeting working on code helping spread
the word
teaching people and just kind of
embracing what i think is one of the
most important technologies in human
history
okay so let's let's start off with some
really simple questions like what is
bitcoin
that's like actually really different
yeah i thought you might say that
yeah well uh bitcoin is a new form of
money
and unlike most old forms of money it's
a fully digital currency
and unlike other quasi-digital
currencies
like the us dollar instead of being
controlled by
you know a singular institution in the
dollars case the federal reserve
it is controlled by a network of people
such that no one is actually in charge
it's just kind of a
protocol that that runs on its own
according to its own rules
and because of that no one is able to
exert
their you know their own
power over it to change the rules in
their favor
so with the federal reserve especially
in the past
you know current events they've decided
to inject
trillions of dollars so you know they'll
even you know come on 60 minutes
and explicitly say that you know they're
printing money digitally
or that they have infinite money
effectively
they can just keep printing and printing
and
the problem with that is that money
doesn't just you know go to everyone
in fact even if it did just if everyone
woke up with
more money that wouldn't necessarily
help anyone it would just change the
prices
but instead when people print money it
goes to someone first
and that first person is whoever is
friends or politically connected
with the money printer and so in the
federal reserve's case whoever they
decide they want to
give money to they have a sort of first
player advantage with the money
and they get to spend it before the rest
of the economy is able to catch up so
it's a very
unfair advantage this is why politicians
like ron paul have referred to
you know inflation as a sort of tax
because the people who are not
friends with the money printers they
have to deal with much higher prices in
the future because
they did not have access to that new
money but with bitcoin
because no one is in charge one
you get to hold on to your own money
you're not trusting a bank to not
loan out money that you actually just
wanted to sit in a bank account
safe and sound and you also do not have
to worry about
your money being diluted because there
is a set supply that is
managed by the network and can't be
tampered unless everyone in the network
agrees to it
so because of this bitcoin has solved
some very fundamental problems that have
you know plagued
just the concept of money in general
since antiquity
and now we get to work with something
brand new that that actually
fixes these problems and you know offers
us a chance to build
a much stronger economy okay that's
interesting
i i never had experience with banks
being problematic really until
i went to russia and they would only let
us withdraw a certain amount
per month and we were only there for a
few weeks
and that was my first taste of oh this
this banking thing
could be an issue yeah i think in
america we don't and
and north america i guess to include you
is we don't have to face as much of the
in your face problems of banking cartels
instead what we have to deal with is
basically pervasive
inflation so they're just constantly
diluting the money in the background
and you know you over over
decades prices are skyrocketed
compared to what they used to be meaning
that someone who had wanted to just put
away money for savings
then finds themselves decades later not
actually having having anything and so
we find ourselves very interested in
investing in stocks
and investing in real estate not that
those things are bad but
i think that they're over incentivized
because we need to beat inflation
somehow
okay so how do you feel about bitcoin as
an
investment strategy so
one of the the uh phrases that i really
like i think
my friend pierre richard was the first
to kind of coin it is talking about
bitcoin as savings technology
and so there can be a bit of a blurry
line between investment
and savings but i think bitcoin is
more on the savings side or at least i
think that
people who are thinking about bitcoin
should be thinking of it more
as a vehicle for savings rather than
like a investment the way you would
invest in a stock
because the the point of it is to act
more
as just a cash balance and in economics
a cash balance is
you know you just have money in your
wallet because at this moment in time
you are uncertain about the future if
you knew exactly what you want you
wouldn't need money because
you could just have the thing you wanted
you would trade exactly for it but
instead you keep some money in your
wallet in case you're walking around
and you come across something you want
that you hadn't known you wanted
previously
so holding a cash balance is a sort of
hedge against uncertainty
when when you when you buy bitcoin
the real macro you know
importance of it has to do i think with
that hedge against uncertainty because
it is
extremely certain every 10 minutes a new
block is mined and we can talk about
what that means
but basically the network continues to
just run according to its rules
the supply remains statistically
expected you know you at any moment in
time you can know
you know if you have x number of
bitcoins you have that much of the
bitcoin economy in your wallet
and so you always have that certainty
about
what you have in your wallet an
investment is more
sort of risky in the sense of like
you're you're putting money
into something for the production
of other goods that you think will have
value in the marketplace
but money itself is not it's not an
investment it's something you hold
just to have on hand and so you know in
in bitcoin's history people have seen
massive gains and i do happen to believe
that there are still
the the purchasing power of bitcoin is
still going to skyrocket very much
but the the overall purpose of bitcoin
and the mindset that i think people
should have when thinking about bitcoin
is in terms of money and savings rather
than
a sort of get rich stock
if that makes sense yeah that makes
sense so
would that kind of be like i know you
said
it's not like an investment but would
that kind of be like
investing into gold just to have a
different type of
money yes i mean so
there's going to be a lot of different
investment theses in bitcoin people have
a lot of different reasons why they want
to
purchase it so some people they have
bitcoins because they want to make
purchases
that are unable to be made other than
through bitcoin some of these are
innocuous others are not so innocuous in
the case of
you know buying drugs online or
something like that
but then other people yeah they they
actually do treat it more like how
gold is treated in modern times which is
as a sort of
hedge against inflation and sort of a a
hedge against you know doomsday
but and i i do think that bitcoin has
those abilities because it has all the
properties we like about gold but more
but it also is just plain good money
and i actually i i don't think that
bitcoin relies on doomsday to have its
heyday
yeah well doomsday might be here so
might have his heyday
sooner rather than later who knows i was
hoping that it would have its heyday for
uh
better reasons just by you know winning
but if it has to save the day outright
then
so be it well we can hope okay you
talked about
bitcoin mining now what what does that
mean
yeah so the way that bitcoin works
is that this is it it's such a difficult
question
to to get across in a a way that someone
could possibly understand by listening
to a 10-minute rant
so whatever i say forever for whoever is
listening you know don't feel bad if uh
it's going over your head it could be
that i'm not explaining it as well as i
could
it's also just not an easy concept to to
grasp
but i think most most bitcoiners took
some time to really grok it
yeah well if you can explain it to me i
feel like we we can get somewhere so
let's try okay well then you'll be a
good uh gauge for this so
with with a centralized money
being able to come to an agreement about
who has
what is very simple you just ask the guy
in charge
so if you go to the store and you try to
swipe your credit card
it pings visa and visas bank or whatever
in the back end and some guy
some centralized service looks at their
database and they say
yes that person has that money and then
they say approved
and the the money gets transferred to a
different account
if they don't have it then the person
says no they don't have this and it's
denied
it's very simple to do that check
however
with bitcoin we don't want someone in
charge because we have to trust that
person doesn't print money
that they don't censor transactions that
they don't
aren't able to use their political power
in any way
so you have to come up with a
decentralized solution and this is
a very difficult problem and it
basically wasn't solved until bitcoin
came along
and the way it does that is it has
what's called
proof of work and proof of work means
that
if anyone wants to add to the ledger
that everyone shares
so every bitcoin node has a copy of the
entire transaction history
if you want to add to that and adding to
it
can net you a reward you get what's
called the block reward
then you have to do
a a mathematical function on the
information for the new block
that effectively shows that you expended
a lot of energy to do so
and basically nothing else it's it's
purely just
like the name implies it's just proof of
work it's like did you did you
you know run around in circles a lot and
over the internet this is just done with
that with a hash function that has a
sort of
statistical expectation of of how hard
it is to create a particular hash
so imagine if you're flipping quarters
and someone asked you it's like
i will accept your block if you can
prove to me
that you flipped a quarter heads five
times in a row
each time you ask for an additional coin
flip the difficulty of that
increases it doubles right
it becomes more and more difficult to do
yeah so
a hash function that bitcoin uses for
mining is effectively like that
so imagine that you have this little
economy and everyone's flipping quarters
to try to
get in well you have a problem because
anyone from anywhere in the world can
show up
however they want with whatever they
want
and someone might show up with a big
quarter flipping machine
so they do that and now they're flipping
you know a gazillion quarters at once
and they can easily get it
the bitcoin network has a an interesting
way to deal with this
which is to increase the difficulty
according to how much proof of work had
been added to the network in the past
two weeks
meaning had someone shown up with one of
those brand new machines
and by doing so it's able to keep this
process
at a kind of steady rate so the idea is
that a block is mined
every 10 minutes you want to make sure
someone statistically will
find one of these hashes of a particular
difficulty
every 10 minutes and the the network is
able to
to adjust for this fact okay so i think
i'm kind of getting this there was a
while there i was like this is yeah
please ask questions this is going to be
difficult and we should we should switch
to just how to use it
but but so mining bitcoin the difficult
the purpose of the difficulty
is almost the same as mining gold right
if it making it rare now it's analogous
yes
yeah okay okay that's cool
yeah and something i didn't i didn't
mention by the way and i i
should have when when you receive a
block like i have
i have a full node running and every 10
minutes or so you know
it's it's it can vary because you know
people randomness
happens so sometimes it actually takes
like a minute sometimes it'll take 40
minutes
but every time a new block shows up my
block goes through
i mean my node goes through the block
and verifies that all the transactions
have valid cryptographic signatures it
makes sure that the proof of work was
difficult enough and that it was valid
et cetera et cetera now when they send
that
the interesting thing about all of these
cryptographic properties
that bitcoin is using for instance like
making a signature
that says that the this this transaction
was
authorized by me all of these kinds of
mathematical functions are designed
to be very difficult to produce you know
with the signatures it's
only if you have one particular number
in the universe a very very large number
would you be able to produce this
signature but to verify it
is extremely simple and a computer can
easily do it
and likewise with the with the hash
functions
it's very difficult i mean you have you
have warehouses all over the world that
are
pumping out untold amounts of hashes per
second
but once the block comes to my node it
takes
very little effort for my computer to be
like yes that's a valid hash
and so everyone else can check that the
work was valid
very easily but it's extremely difficult
to produce
so i as a user can have that check on
the network the miners can't just give
me any old block they want because i can
go through and check it and make sure
it actually lived up to the rules i
believe it should live up to
okay that's interesting and just to back
up a little bit
a node that's just you what exactly is a
node
yeah so a node a node is a person on the
network
or like a computer on the network that
is validating transactions
a full node would mean someone who has
has
validated transactions for the entirety
of the history of bitcoin so right now
that's like
they've crunched through about 300
gigabytes of data and they've made sure
every step of it was valid and now going
forward they're checking everything
that's coming in
that's a full node and a term people
also use is
economic full node which is actually the
important one which is
a full node that people are actually
using to
verify their balances against so when i
receive bitcoins i don't want to just
you know ask
you know as an analogy just like go to
chase.com and ask them hey
did i get my money instead i want to go
to my own node
that's been crunching this data and
verifying that everything along the way
is cryptographically valid
and has the satisfactory proof of work
and i want to see if that tells me that
i've received my money and because of
that
i have the a full fully you know
trustless ability to know that i have
the money i think i have
and know that no power on earth can stop
that unless they you know come and smash
my computer
okay that's really cool well i'm glad
that was explained because
that that makes sense and the analogy of
just gold mining
digitally makes sense the difficult
because i was like what's the point
why is it so hard this is like that
seems overly complicated but
if it's similar to mining for something
that's you know
expensive or valuable then that actually
does make sense
that's very cool right okay okay so then
let's
let's switch from that topic that was
really helpful that actually clarified a
lot
how do how do people get started and i
know yeah so are there apps you could
recommend
because my difficulty getting started
was first of all i'm in canada so
i couldn't get into a whole bunch of the
american apps and then
it was hard like it was hard enough that
it's going to stop
most people from trying to use it and i
assume doesn't the ease of use of
like doesn't it have to get easier to
use in order for people to
start using it isn't that one of the
problems with bitcoin now
it's it's a problem in certain ways i
don't think that it's a
i don't think it's like a fatal problem
because
you know people can also step up and
learn
if they value bitcoin enough which also
might be enough to to raise the price
regardless if a lot of people who
haven't learned haven't if that makes
sense but
yes i do believe i mean i i want
onboarding
to bitcoin to be as easy as possible so
i certainly think that
it would improve the the bitcoin economy
every time that someone is able to
improve that experience as far as
getting started if
if you're not in america there's a
website
run by a friend of mine called
buybitcoinworldwide.com
that people can go to and it has a lot
of different exchanges you can put in
what country you're in what kind of
payment you want to do
like you want to do a bank transfer or
paypal or whatever
it will give you some options of where
you might be able to purchase bitcoin
in america we thankfully have a lot more
options and including i think the
easiest one which is
squares cash app which has bitcoin built
right into it
and after putting in you know necessary
kyc
information because you know fiat money
begets fiat problems
they have bitcoin right there that you
can just say i want five bucks and you
hit
buy and it buys it so that makes it very
easy to
to actually onboard but as far as like
getting into it
you know dipping your toes in is is a
good
first step to like actually just buy
your first five dollars of bitcoin just
so you kind of have that skin in the
game and it's like
you know no matter what happens with it
you get to take part
but the other really big important thing
is just education
because you know many listeners probably
had never even heard the term
hash function before and yet it's this
absolutely vital thing to kind of grok
how this money even works and
bitcoin offers self-sovereignty
you know it offers financial sovereignty
you know you can have complete control
over your financial future however at
the same time
in order to take full responsibility for
that
you have a lot to learn because now it's
on you you sort of have to kind of
you kind of have to peer back but behind
some of the scenes in in the
you know bitcoin banking process so to
speak and and see how the guts work so
you can
make the best use of it so there's a lot
of education involved just to kind of
understand
you know more of how bitcoin works what
isn't a bitcoin address
you know what what does it mean to make
a bitcoin
transaction all these little things then
a lot of people also still have
questions about well why is it even
important in the first place
and thankfully now there's a lot of good
literature around
on this topic whereas you know back back
when i
got into bitcoin it was laughable how
little information there was online
and so it was very difficult to to find
anything but people have written many
great books and many great articles now
for for those kinds of things so
learning is
the biggest one i recommend to people
before moving on to the
the more practical but so yeah cash
cash app is a very good place to start
in terms of purchasing bitcoin because
it is so easy
and from there depending on you know
people's learning and
and what kind of investment they want to
put into it like how much
how much money do they want to be saving
in bitcoin
versus other things will present a
number of other questions as well
yeah it's going to be tricky like i was
vaguely interested in bitcoin when
wow when it skyrocketed in value and
everybody started talking about bitcoin
was like whoa this is kind of cool but
you know do i need it and i didn't need
it and then
eventually i came across some website
where it was like you take
payments only in bitcoin and i was like
really that's really annoying
and so then i then i like kind of forced
myself into
learning and buying some just so i could
make a purchase so i
i think that it takes a very unique
individual to go out and learn a
complicated
method of payment unless they're forced
into it
because even for me it was difficult to
difficult and time consuming just to
start and i started
with i don't know if you know them but i
used an app called brd
and coinberry those are the canadian app
i guess
brd maybe is a website i can't remember
or it's an app
i think it's a bread wallet yeah that's
a phone app
okay so i used those two and they made
it okay but it was still like
you know by bitcoin that takes a while
and then
transferring these random numbers that
are coming up on my screen
oh man yeah and wha why does it take so
long you know compared to
visa which and visa is different right
because you they don't immediately
receive the funds so it's not actually
visa isn't
instant even though it feels instant
yeah yes so yeah it's gonna be true i'm
glad that you understand that because a
lot of people don't they think
you know people think that bitcoin is
competing with visa
so it's like why is it not as good of a
payment system as visa
but visa is actually it only has the
illusion of being fast it actually takes
a very long time weeks
to finally settle and in the meantime i
mean that exists because of all kinds of
you know dealing with chargeback and
fraud and all of that
which can actually be a burden on the
merchants
but really visa itself is like a layer 5
system on the usd
stack you know they're they're built on
other stuff and so bitcoin is
is more like the fundamental dollar you
know like
yeah the payment rails between the
federal
federal
reserve banks not not visa yeah
it's interesting the the way i learned
about visa because i i never thought
about any of that right
you don't really think about it if
you're just paying with visa and it's
money seems like it disappears from your
account right away but again i was in
russia
and we were trying to pay cabs by visa
and they were just like please
no like if you pay this way i don't
receive my money for two weeks and i
can't buy gas
i was like oh okay this is slightly
different than i thought it was
yeah that's very interesting yeah okay
so let me think other questions
so you gave us a step-by-step kind of
website
is there you know like how much
well i can't ask you that but how much
would you suggest
people start out with like or say
somebody has
let's say somebody has 50k worth of
savings that they want to
put into investments or put into
different forms of saving
do you have a percentage of or an amount
that you think would be a good idea for
people to
buy in bitcoin the the typical thing
that i
i see from people who are actual you
know investors and financial planners
and trying to give people a serious
comment on
on bitcoin investing will tend to say
you know one to five percent
of a portfolio going into bitcoin would
be
a a good allocation to think about
but uh i i i don't i don't want to like
make give financial advice per se
because you know
i'm late one to five percent i heard it
i mean more like 99 99.5
you know but yeah but basically i i
think
another thing people should consider by
the way is is thinking in terms of
dca or dollar cost averaging
and okay dollar cost averaging means
that
instead of a lump sump buy of
a good so like in this case like you
know say
say you have you're putting a thousand
dollars into bitcoin or something like
that
lump sum would be oh i'm gonna just put
it all in right now
dollar cost averaging would be how about
i split it up
over this many days or weeks or months
so every
every week you go on and you buy x
amount
so that it takes a little longer for you
to actually allocate all of the one
thousand dollars
but you're just kind of doing it
steadily now
there's contention as to you know what
what you actually want to do
if you have the money available to just
throw at it
you know many people have different
things but once again i think of bitcoin
in terms of savings
so i'm i think of dca as
a strategy for just a kind of average
person
who is working a job and
they want to think like hey every time
i'm getting up my paycheck you know i
have a budget
i put some money into you know rent
all that kind of stuff i have my
entertainment budget and then i have my
savings budget
and you know all every every month i'll
put in you know a hundred dollars into
bitcoin
so you just kind of have it on a on an
auto buy and actually cash app
and a number of different apps such as
river.com
and swan bitcoin they offer auto dca so
you can say
i want a recurring buy and so it just
automatically does it and so
that's really good for people who you
know they have they have cash flow
restrictions so
they're they're not sitting on a large
pile and they also so they
they can't just go through a bunch of
money at an investment but they also
want to you know kind of get in over
time this has benefits too because
you know bitcoin is uh notoriously
volatile
and so dca has a number of psychological
benefits such as
you get to dip your toes in without you
know
totally setting yourself up for getting
wrecked so if
if it drops to zero tomorrow it's like
well i only put in my five dollars
and you're kind of just you're you're
easing your way into it
but you also at the same time you don't
you don't
have to get as concerned about the lows
because it's it tends to be much more
long-term thinking
in fact i don't think people should be
thinking about bitcoin unless they're
thinking on a
you know five plus year time horizon
and and so it kind of you it can it can
be
crazy for a new person to see the crazy
price swings and it's like you wake up
one day and it's you know gone up
a thousand dollars and you wake up the
next day and it's gotten down 2
000 and uh that that can be very
psychologically taxing for a new person
over time you become very battle hard
and
and you make fun of the stock people for
you know
yeah they're a little uh you know blip
in the market or whatever but
you know that it's it's psychologically
taxing and this is a way to sort of
you you flatten out those variabilities
so that can be very helpful for a new
person yeah that's helpful to know so
then
what do you think about these i see
these people on twitter all the time or
they have some algorithm they're like
follow me
because i can time bitcoin and you can i
mean
obviously there's something wrong there
but are there people
who are able to sell i guess they must
sell multiple times per day
in order to make some sort of quick buck
what do you think about that
i i think trading is is a bit of a scam
there are traders who are very good at
what they do i'm sure
but most of that is feeding into the get
rich quick
mentality that people have getting into
bitcoin
whereas in reality you should be focused
on the long term
if if bitcoin is a viable technology
it's because of its long-term
potential not because it's it could have
10x gains tomorrow
even though it very well could the other
thing is
bitcoin because it's very volatile
you really it's it's extremely dangerous
to think you can time the market
and this is also what's nice about dca
is you know we
historically bitcoin kind of just like
stays
chill maybe even kind of slight slightly
uh decreases over time and then
one day it just skyrockets i think it's
something like
most price movements every year is
within the span of about 14 days
but you also don't know when
specifically those 14 days
are so by just steadily accumulating
you're
saving in a more like kind of rational
long-term
method such that you know whenever that
happens to happen
you are ready and you're not going to
get blindsided so
some of those people might get lucky and
they might do great but it's also a very
very
very easy way to get wrecked and
getting wrecked is not a good long-term
strategy
yeah okay so if bitcoin i mean
the way you've explained it it makes
sense and
the fact that nobody owns it is awesome
because
governments certainly aren't trustworthy
as we are finding out
now but why why is bitcoin so
volatile if this is you know a more
evolved method
so i think the main reason is that it is
a
nascent currency it's only existed since
january
and so it's a brand new thing that the
whole world is trying to figure out
and additionally you know
given only a decade that's only going to
convince
a certain class of people that it's
worthy of being paid attention to
and there's kind of a a need for bitcoin
to continually prove
itself until more people come in and
when there are fewer people in it it's
going to be
less liquid and more susceptible to
various you know short-term price swings
you know one guy i can go on the market
and dump a lot of money
and the whole market reacts whereas in
the future
like once you've kind of proven to
everyone that this works and it kind of
it builds up in the liquidity you know
if someone dumps a bunch of money no one
even notices
the way that i think sorry no no you go
ahead
oh i just say if uh like today with
dollars if someone goes and buys a
16 million dollar mansion the economy
doesn't even blink
but if someone did that with bitcoin
there actually might be
a small short-term price swing and so
it's just a matter of it being a new
thing that the world is having to figure
out
and as time goes on as more people get
into bitcoin
it becomes more liquid and less
susceptible to that and i
i think you said you've talked to safe
and i'm sure he talked a bit about the
hardness of money
and that sort of effect on the macro
adoption of money
yeah okay so the reason it's volatile
right now is because
is mainly because people are buying and
selling
large amounts of it is that the main
reason
well we we can see big price
like you you can watch the markets and
you'll see someone dump a lot of
bitcoins or buy a lot of bitcoins so
there is a bit of that
i actually don't subscribe too many
narratives to bitcoin because
i i don't have enough information about
what everyone in the world is
thinking about with regards to bitcoin
it is a global currency where everyone
you know a guy in japan can be dumping
money and it would affect the market
just as much as a guy
in new york so it makes it it can be
make it rather difficult to simply look
at it and kind of make a
a judgment about it but
the the important thing i think to sort
of
step out a bit is that when when you're
looking for what makes a good monetary
good
what matters are sort of the fundamental
qualities of
divisibility durability etc etc all the
things that you've kind of heard about
before
especially scarcity but the
the actual price is a function of just
how much people actually demand it so
bitcoin is a free floating currency
there's no
there's no federal reserve of bitcoin to
adjust the bitcoin interest rate to make
it have a different
purchasing power so because of that you
know it is
it is totally at the whim of global
supply and demand
supply is extremely fixed and so it's
it's
purely you know demand at a given time
changes
now there's there's reasons to believe
that demand itself
increases because bitcoin grows so like
you were saying that everyone was
talking about bitcoin because it
skyrocketed and suddenly you got into it
bitcoiners have a meme about number go
up and
i've seen that points yeah so it's like
the the underlying technology of bitcoin
is number go up
and it's basically saying money you know
earlier i talked about how it's a hedge
against uncertainty
well one of the ways to reduce
uncertainty
is to know that you can spend a good
anywhere you please so like you know i
carry dollars with me
because i know that any store in america
is going to take us dollars
however i don't carry around marbles
with me not only because they're not
scarce
but also it's because they're not scarce
that's not monetary good
but you know maybe there's like one kid
who will trade me lemonade for
marbles but you know i can't just go
anywhere and take it and so
when the price goes up it means that
there's there's more liquidity
in it so it's actually more capable of
allowing for economic trade you know
right now the
market cap is you know about 170 billion
or so
something like that that would be a
little
too too little for say governments to be
doing massive you know monetary trades
between each other
and so there's like a sort of limit to
what kind of
economics can happen within the bitcoin
economy if that makes
any sense and so if number goes up
because
a lot of people demand it more and the
price is suddenly higher
that increases the liquidity and now
more economic trade
is able to go through it and there
there's
there's many many feedback loops going
into this
but basically you know more people will
have
an interest in bitcoin because they have
that sense that it'll be
more widely accepted widely demanded
yeah yeah that totally makes sense okay
next question
are there areas of the world where
bitcoin is more popular like is it more
popular
in in asia for instance and we're just
not seeing it in north america
so i think in north america it is very
very popular
and in many parts of asia it's also very
popular
i think those are probably the two
biggest markets
okay and i i would guess that that
europe follows
okay um most of the places i've seen
using bitcoin it was like my corner
store which is run by
some an asian dude or websites that are
from china so it's been like
specifically
asian that i guess
i've seen using it but you know that's
not a very big sample size
right so there is a very large market
china and japan
and korea well one thing i'll note is it
would also be difficult just to
look at who is accepting it
because there's also demand for bitcoin
doesn't only come in the form
of businesses demanding bitcoin it's
also just plain individuals who
want to be saving a much harder asset
so you just have individual saving for
the future
some businesses also demand it but they
also
might demand it purely because they
think someone will give them the money
and they're going to just go sell the
bitcoins themselves
they're not really they they demand they
actually demand dollars or whatever they
just
will are willing to use bitcoin as sort
of the payment rail
okay that makes sense okay what do you
think about
other coins like and and what is bitcoin
cash
all [ __ ] coins okay so
yes so this is a this is a been a a
contentious topic for many years now but
yeah i think that
basically every other coin besides
bitcoin
uh has not has not proven itself as a
viable
global reserve currency and in the world
of monetary competition
you either have to go big or go home so
you either have to be going for the king
or just not bothering because with money
you don't want many monies you don't
want to have to carry around
20 different types of money in your
pocket if you don't have to
it would it would suck for instance if
you had to go if you had your 7-eleven
bucks
and you had your walmart box and you had
your amazon bucks
no instead you just want your dollars so
you can spend it everywhere so
people some people like they believe
that we're going to live in a sort of
multi-coin
future but those people are effectively
wanting to take us back to a state of
barter
because they want to they want this gift
card economy where you have to
spend you know a different currency at
every different place like everyone's
going to issue their own currency and
you're going to spend that there it's
like that that that does not alleviate
the costs of transaction that just makes
it more difficult
so that's not a very good argument for
it and
and then for those who are trying to
actually outright compete with bitcoin
the problem is they either pretend like
they aren't competing so an example
would be ethereum
where they'll say it is it is bitcoin
is gold whereas ethereum is like oil
you know it's like a it's a different
kind of asset because it's
selling computing stuff but you still
ultimately like you
in order to use the computation engine
of
ethereum you still have to purchase
ethers
and it's effectively still a money all
the same
it's so it's just it's just slicker
marketing to sort of hide that fact
so it's still competing with bitcoin
as a money so then it gets into probably
like the the important
argument there which is bitcoin is the
money
that not only has has it empirically
been the top contender but it's also
just
the best at addressing the needs
of bitcoin and and of a
scalable money in the sense that
bitcoin unlike some coins you know
different coins will vary but
some coins for instance are just not as
focused
on security you know bitcoin
puts a an extreme emphasis on making
sure
it is a secure system because if it is
to work as a global currency
you can't have any security yeah you
can't have
the signature algorithm suddenly fail on
you
you can't have inflation bugs and that
isn't to say that bitcoin hasn't faced
bugs before
but the the emphasis is on security
whereas for instance ethereum they tend
to
want to fix things after they've been
exploited
you know so there's more of uh just like
well it's like the silicon valley move
fast and break things
when you're dealing with a global
economy you don't want to move fast and
break things you want to get things
right the first time
and bitcoin tends to be like that then
with forks of bitcoin oh sorry another
thing before i get to the fork
specifically
you have coins that try to offer
some new feature you know so a famous
one many years ago is still around it's
still actually one of the most popular
but
litecoin it was selling itself as quote
unquote faster
it was it had a different hashing out
algorithm which they claimed was
less susceptible to centralization and
stuff like this none of these feature
claims were actually true
and additionally some of the features
that some
coins offer so like ethereum has what's
called
turing completeness so it just means
that the
the kinds of contracts that can be run
on the system
they're very complex it's like it's a
whole computer program
whereas bitcoin's smart contracting is
is
very specific and and straightforward
because
it wants to be highly secure but the
thing is is
just because you know ethereum is able
to offer
turing completeness even if that wasn't
a total security flaw
even though we've seen many hacks due to
how they have the contract and even if
that wasn't the problem
they still haven't tightened up the
monetary policy in fact i don't think
there's a single person in the world
who can tell me how much ethereum there
will be
ever you know whereas bitcoin has that
certainty
i can i can run two commands on my on my
node
to get all the information i would
possibly need about the bitcoin economy
without asking anyone with these other
coins you don't necessarily have that
so where am i getting with that it's
that you can offer new features
but unless it it it's not only adding
on the sort of fundamental needs of a
globally scalable
currency but also adding on it in like a
10 to 100
x fashion you're not actually adding
anything you're just kind of
once again doing slick marketing and
bitcoin has always been focused on
getting
the actual currency just right and
and focused on that and so that means
that people are able to pretend like it
isn't as
innovative even though that it is
innovating all the time
but they don't you know it's not
constantly adding in like
you know crazy things because it sounds
good which tends to just be
like you know people are pumping and
dumping it's a people found a way to
print money themselves
and they will want in on the action and
they'll make up whatever they need to to
try to get in on that
okay with the forks so with the fork
specifically
uh did you did you have a question no no
just listening it's
interesting i had a question i guess
about bitcoin cash
what the difference between what that is
and what that is
let me get into that then so that gets
into the forks basically in bitcoin
there was
a contentious argument for many years
which finally culminated in a split
in 2017 with the creation of what's
called bitcoin cash
and the contention had to do with the
size of bitcoin blocks
so right now or actually previously
so at near the beginning of bitcoin i
think in i think it may have been
late 2009 maybe even early 2010
satoshi nakamoto the creator of bitcoin
added a
block size limit as a spam mechanism
so that was saying like a node will not
accept a block that has more than one
megabyte of data
and the reason is is you don't want
someone who makes a block that's like 10
gigs of data
and then it shows up on your little
computer and
your computer isn't even able to process
it and it just shuts down
that would be a good way of you know a
denial of service attack
and so satoshi added this in now a lot
of people thought oh we should be
getting rid of this
but there were a couple reasons why you
would not want to get rid of it one
was because in order to do so it's
what's called a hard fork
and a hard fork means that you're adding
rules
that are not backwards compatible
so it means that anyone who wants to
participate
in a hard forked coin must upgrade their
software
but because bitcoin isn't under anyone's
control
you can't force everyone to upgrade
their software
and so for anyone who's holding out
you're kind of stuck holding the bag
meanwhile you know so yeah that that's a
a
big issue we can get further into that
later if you'd like but
the other reason is you know quite
frankly as a
an operator of a full node and i rely on
my full node to tell me trustlessly how
much money i have
you know i don't want to end up with
blocks that my computer can't run
and i also you know don't want to do
that
you know if if it puts too much of a
burden on on other people's
abilities to do that in a trustless
manner because we want as many people
be able to do this trustlessly as
possible
and they decided that they had
enough with the the block size limit and
they forked
and created a hard fork that increased
the block size limit
where actually when they forked it
bitcoin went through what's called a
soft fork which is
uses backwards compatible upgrades so
bitcoin added a new feature called
segregated witness which is very cool
that these people didn't like it
but that actually increased the block
size limit itself
so blocks and bitcoin tend to be about
two two megabytes now
so there's there's actually no longer a
one megabyte block size limit
but it did so in a way that was able to
do it without hard forking which was
itself a really interesting thing but
anyway
they they did this and so basically the
the main pitch of bitcoin cash and it's
an additional fork that forked off that
one over
actually similar contentious issues
called called bsv
they are under the impression that
bitcoin
can operate with very large blocks
whereas the people in bitcoin one don't
want to hard fork
because it puts the the network at risk
you know you can't you can't be
assertive about your money after a hard
fork
but also it means you know how can i be
sure that in the future
i can run a full node and actually
verify the transactions if you need to
if you need to buy a super computer in
order to verify your own money
that's a little too much yeah okay
so they they were focused on that which
i believe in the long run
i i if if
they were able to grow to the scale of
bitcoin and face
similar liquidity they're very small
compared to bitcoin but if they were
similar
i think they would be facing a lot of
centralization pressures
and i think many especially in bsv
already
face a lot of centralization pressures
in the sense
they do not run full nodes so they rely
on third-party services to give them
transaction data
and there is not as much of a culture of
you know using using more sovereign
like the sovereign node and and stack
so they use centralized wallet services
as well very often
where they might hold the keys but
they're
they're once again relying on a third
party to actually
manage the data whereas a bitcoiner
does not want to put up with any of that
we want to be able to hold our own keys
and be sovereign over the data that
we're operating
with yeah so bitcoin cash was
theoretically trying to make it simpler
for people
maybe by getting rid of like part of the
reason people use bitcoin
well they were increasing the block size
limit because
the block size limit means that there's
a limit to how many transactions can
occur in each block
and so their idea is that if you don't
allow more transactions per block
then bitcoin cannot scale to say visa
level
transactions transaction volume
okay and and so you know they think that
that's not as good for
you know just normal people like you you
would have to be you know very rich in
order to use it because the fees will be
very high
whereas bitcoiners you know for one
uh you know i i do not think that
bitcoin will hard fork
but i think if there was a a large
enough pressure of people
actually not using bitcoin because the
fees were too high
i think you know there there would be a
little bit more of a community
interest in raising the block size limit
but
you know there's no need to put that
cart before the horse
okay that makes because because of the
risks that it poses
yeah oh yeah yeah okay okay that's cool
well i caught on there by the end that
does make sense
okay do i have i don't think i have any
more main
questions about bitcoin but some of the
things i've been asking just any of the
guests on my show
that are you know interesting
individuals
that are fairly successful is what their
day kind of looks like
so that be when do you wake up when you
go to bed
how many hours do you sleep how many
hours do you work
and what does your diet look like
i i live you know a pretty boring life i
i probably sleep about seven or eight
hours
wake up early in the morning usually go
to bed and kind of somewhat early
and i work work a handful of hours today
like really focused work and then
yeah as far as diet i'm i'm a carnivore
and have been for many years now
yeah so how did you get how did you get
into that when did you start
so i became interested in paleo stuff in
early college
and later on i kind of i learned about
keto
and i specifically learned about keto
from amber o'hearn
and her now ex-husband because of a
presentation just you know about the
greatness of keto and
and because of that i i found amber's
blog
and you know she's like oh well if you
want to try keto the best way is to just
eat only meat and i thought that was
interesting and kind of crazy
and i forgot about it and about a year
later or sometime in 2015 i
i came across it again and i dug into it
a bit more i found some of the
online communities like zeroing in on
health
of kind of these these people who were
doing it with great success
i found you know the the
forum posts of owsley stanley talking
about
you know his experiences with it you
know over the course of five decades
and you know i i read wilhelmer
stephenson's book
and all of this is just like it
it i didn't i believed it it was crazy
but i also i believed in this stuff it's
like you're not going to die
if you only eat meat which at the time
like i would eat keto but i was like
throwing some broccoli because it's like
oh i need
greens because you just if you don't eat
broccoli you'll die
but you know that kind of feeling yeah
yeah i had that it was
yeah it was like oh i just don't eat the
broccoli so i stopped doing that
and you know i i wasn't like
particularly
unhealthy it wasn't for extreme health
reasons i did it
i tell people i just i like being right
online so being a carnivore just made me
more right online
so you know i just did but i i felt
great
and you know a lot of little things did
kind of
you know get better in my life and i
just have felt generally better than i
did
prior to this you know despite being
interested in paleo and keto and whatnot
so i i've stuck to it and i i just have
never had a reason to go back
okay so how so that's what four years
now
yeah it's been quite a while wow okay
you don't miss broccoli i miss broccoli
i i don't no and
there there were times where i missed so
i was uh i was a fast food junkie and a
soda junkie and all that
as a kid you know growing up probably
until i got into
paleo and even then i was cheating a lot
but
you know i i did find near the beginning
of doing carnivore i
reminisce about you know say dr pepper
or something but
like oddly enough i'd finally was like i
could remember the taste
and i could also remember how bad i felt
after i drank it
yeah so i was able to just remember the
taste i was like oh yes that was a good
taste and i moved on with my day
hmm i don't know if that's like a weird
you know stoic exercise or whatever but
it worked for me
so it's just reminiscing yeah i remember
i remember how awful i used to feel so
that
definitely deters me from missing food
too much i think what's going on now is
i'm 36 hours into a fast and i'm just
remembering food in general
yeah yeah that actually could be i'm
like yeah broccoli because normally i
don't think that
okay what about exercise you do any
exercise for yourself
these days i i have not had as much time
and i guess i should have been doing
more
prison workouts during the imprisonment
of 2020 but
you know i i have done weight lifting
before you know some power lifting some
more kind of you know weightlifting for
putting on muscle and stuff
i do think lifting waste is fantastic
and i do look forward to getting back
into it
okay well where can people find you
online
so the best place is probably twitter so
i'm at bitscene b-i-t-s-t-e-i-n
and there's also the nakamoto institute
chair on which nakamoto institute dot
org
as well as the noted bitcoin podcast at
noted.org
and if you're interested in learning all
of the meats
resources that i collected over the
years because when i first found out
about it was like if i was telling
someone about it it was like that
picture of charlie from
it's always sunny in philadelphia in
front of the pin board just like
you just don't eat vegetables they want
to kill you and you just sound like a
crazy person
and so i put together that website as a
way to be like no no like i've actually
read things
i actually from from a wide variety of
uh sources both reputable and not i
think people underestimate the
non-reputable sources but
yes it was it was my place to my place
to put all that information
to try to help guide people towards
finding stuff because
up until recently it was not it was not
something that was talked about
in the mainstream media or anything now
it's now it's become a fad which
i actually think is pretty exciting but
yeah yeah it is
you know people want to learn bad so
yeah yeah well i definitely recommend
your website has been useful for me so
yeah so that's it justmeet.com
so those are the place best places to
find me and the bitcoin twitter is a
very
friendly friendly place so if you have
any questions you know people are always
you know we talked a little bit about
how to purchase bitcoin but even once
you do that there's like
you know we talked about full nodes and
all of that holding your own keys
all of these sort of are ways that
people can level up
their financial sovereignty and each one
takes
you know some some extra steps and they
can be daunting
but all of it is is very much worth
understanding the trade-offs and the
reasons
why people do x y and z even if you're
not ready for a particular step
the good news is that on bitcoin twitter
if you have any questions about how to
acquire bitcoins how to store bitcoins
how to think about bitcoin
people are totally ready to share their
ideas and expertise and
practical tips so i i recommend you
reach out to us
great that's good to know well thanks
again for coming on
yeah thank you so much it was a real
[Music]
honor
[Music]
you